ROB KENNER: Welcome everybody.
My name is Rob Kenner.
I'm a senior editor
at Complex Media.
And I'm glad that all of
you could join us here
in the flesh and
digitally, virtually around
the Google diaspora.
And I'm joined by Mr. Marc Ecko.
Round of applause.
MARC ECKO: Then they add
like the "roar" track.
You'll just cut that in.
It'll be like [ROAR].
ROB KENNER: Or the Norman
Lear canned laughter.
MARC ECKO: Right, right.
With the delayed hand clap.
ROB KENNER: We're counting
on the laugh lines
to go over really big today.
So please participate.
MARC ECKO: Follow the
applaud signs if you will.
ROB KENNER: So you
may know Marc Ecko
as the designer of the
rhinoceros t-shirts
and as a fly MC.
There's a lot of different
items on his resume.
But today he's here in
the guise of an author.
His book "Unlabel, Selling
You Without Selling Out"
is, as he describes
it, the textbook you
wish you had when
you were in school.
MARC ECKO: Yes.
Yes.
ROB KENNER: Now it's
called "Unlabel."
MARC ECKO: Yes.
ROB KENNER: Tell me what labels
were put on you that you undid.
MARC ECKO: Well,
what I try to do
with the book was build
a kind of a business book
for the creative class.
And in an age where we
have all these efficiencies
of self-broadcasting
because of digital media,
I wanted to write
a book that had
a subtext about
personal branding,
but without being this
patronizing, goopy, personal
branding book, which those
books tend to be like.
So the spirit of
the name "Unlabel"
was-- it had a few meanings.
One, the brand that I launched
was called Ecko Unlimited,
so it's playing up on the U-N
like the "un" from "unlimited."
And secondly, I was playing
up on this notion of the fact
that we-- it's just
human nature-- people
project labels onto us.
They want to organize us in
the world like a product,
if we like it or not,
if we know it or not,
sometimes with good intent
or with decent intent
to make people's
lives more efficient,
sometimes with kind
of not so good intent.
So in a world where people
are so easily spewing
out their persona,
their brand, I
was trying to make
the reader flatfooted
and have kind of an analog
conversation about what
it means to build a personal
brand, what it means to live up
to that brand, the brand
that you perceive-- which
is the label, like
the exterior veneer,
the flourishes, the
outside packaging.
And the label you have to
put to bed at night, which
is the one that's
guts to the skin.
So how do you discern
and distinguish
between your inside brand, your
inside label and your exterior
one?
And how do you not parrot,
either within intent
or with poor intent
or misguided intent
to the perceived skin
to the world brand.
So the book, in a
digital age, tries
to have a not too serious
conversation but something that
helps people understand
my philosophy on branding
and maybe how that might be
helpful to their personal
brand, if it's their personal
singular brand or their group
collective "we" company brand.
ROB KENNER: Now what I
love about the book is
it's not like a typical
sort of Trump book,
where it's all about
the Ws and the Ls
kind of get airbrushed out.
MARC ECKO: Right.
ROB KENNER: To be clear, you did
grow an air brushing business
from your parents garage into
a company with $1 billion
in revenue.
MARC ECKO: That's right.
ROB KENNER: And you
founded Complex Media
which is killing
the game right now.
MARC ECKO: Yup.
ROB KENNER: But let's
talk about the Ls,
because those are
teachable moments.
MARC ECKO: I think
this book is designed
not to be what a lot of
those very 90s-style, Type
A personality business
books, like the guy
parachutes out of the plane
like Richard Branson-style
and doesn't fail.
I think this book
is more of-- instead
of being a book
on greatest hits,
it's more of a book
on my greatest misses.
And I'm someone who really likes
to be honest and even painfully
at times masochistically
honest about my idiosyncrasies,
my failures, just because it's--
I don't believe how failures
are taught to be in school, that
you should be ashamed of them.
Like K through 12, the sentence
we all go through that K
through 12 sentence
that we all get,
no matter the state puts
us through, public, private
or otherwise, we're taught
that failure something
to be embarrassed by.
It's something you ridicule,
something to be ashamed by.
And it's just funny
how in business
that success never really
quite looks like an A,
and failure never
quite looks like an F.
And how much value there is
in the learnings of failure.
So I try to have a really honest
conversation about failure,
and put it out there in a
way that maybe people have
perceived me as this guy
that's built this big business
and has collected all
this stuff-- right?
The trappings of success.
But I didn't make the
book about gushing around
about the stuff I collected.
Like the real value and the
real wealth that I talk about
in the book, the
wealth that matters,
can't really be
counted like money.
And it's funny how the
wealth that matters
can be distributed
differently as well.
ROB KENNER: Definitely.
There is a part
in the book where
you talk about
getting into denim,
and your way of feeling
your way through that.
And I thought that was
an instructive anecdote.
Is there a way you could
boil that down for me?
MARC ECKO: Was that the
part in the book where
I meet with Wu, the
dentist supplier?
I can't remember.
ROB KENNER: Yeah.
And the rivets.
MARC ECKO: Oh, right right,
Look, today the world
we live in, young designers
and young product makers today,
the world's a much
different world.
There's this thing, you guys
probably have heard of it,
it's called Google.
So if you ask it, you can
find out a lot of shit.
Back when I was coming
up, like the Google
was like looking at the
inside label of whatever I
was wearing.
I'd look at the inside of
my Gap hoodie or whatever,
and it was like
"Made in Hong Kong."
Like, where is Hong Kong?
Is that by India?
Much of my education was so so.
But I literally
just packed a bag
and found myself over there.
But was only after
I attempted to try
to figure it all
out in the States.
And that's the anecdote
you're asking about,
where I had found a denim
maker-- I forget where they
were in the South
somewhere-- and they
put like all the rivets and
shanks on in the wrong manner.
And they all popped off.
So I remember shipping
them months late,
and then having-- after we
got the first return-- having
to manually fix that stuff
ourselves in our warehouses.
But there are a lot of
anecdotes like that,
stuff that you don't
really contemplate,
like the consequences
of the things you make
and the complexities of them,
and how they affect your--
you don't anticipate that
they're going to go wrong.
But they do.
ROB KENNER: They do.
MARC ECKO: Yup, they do.
ROB KENNER: But what I
love about your candor
in telling these
stories, is it gets back
to this idea of authenticity,
keeping it real,
in hop hop lingo.
You actually break down
the formula of authenticity
in the book, which is kind
of a closely guarded secret.
I mentioned that Malcolm
Gladwell gave you
props for attempting to
break down authenticity.
It's sort of akin to
the Google algorithm.
How do you penetrate the
mystery of authenticity.
MARC ECKO: I think it
was a little bit what
a part of the book is
about, and the book
being framed like a
textbook, was a little bit
taking the piss out of these
kind of prescriptive methods
of arriving at a best practice,
as if you could really
prescribe an for authenticity.
It's like we all bought
into that whole e equals
mc squared thing, but I
mean, have we vetted it.
Really?
Like we all just
agree, because you
see the guy with the crazy hair.
And we were all told "genius."
And I mean yeah,
I'm not trying to--
ROB KENNER: Well, guys with
crazy hair are always geniuses.
MARC ECKO: Right, I mean,
I know this from Rob.
So we all know this, right?
But to your point, hop hop
and coming up in the '80s
when hip hop was this thing
you had to go find it.
It didn't find you in the
way that it kind of is so
woven into popular culture and
consumer products and our media
narratives and our language.
So there was in its kind
of prepubescent phase,
hip hop had this
awkwardness about it,
about its comfort or lack of
comfort around commercializing
itself, around quote
"crossing over."
So there was a lot
of tension coming up
in the '80s around
"keeping it real"
and this notion of
what's real, what's not,
what's authentic, what's not.
And there were all kinds
of layers of subtext there
that, depending on who you
ask, had different meanings.
But that was certainly
something that
was one of the things
that kind of dogged hip
hop in its kind of early
prepubescent years.
Even to this day, real hard
core hip hop enthusiasts
will take a default,
almost cynical view
on anything that
tries to commercialize
in a certain way, where the
monetization strategy is
kind of overt.
Less today, but certainly
when I was coming up.
So that was a theme in
the subtext of my story
and is a part of the book.
that kind of always having an
answer to quote "gatekeepers,"
who would challenge what
was authentic or not.
So not being kind of blue blood
pedigree fashion designer,
you can imagine what it was
like to get into the CFDA.
And I talk about
that in the book.
The Council of Fashion
Designers of America.
And some of those
kind of cultural I'll
use the word-- prejudices
that that ecosystem has
as gatekeepers around street
wear and urban fashion design.
MARC ECKO: Just the
word urban in itself.
ROB KENNER: Right, its
like so loaded, right?
So that's not real
fashion design.
It's not authentic.
And then all the way down to
like coming up in my Rutgers
college age is like, look,
white Jewish kid, into hip hop,
going to Rutgers, it was nothing
like Lakewood in that Lakewood
was kind of this
microcosm, and then
Rutgers is much more
of a macrochosm of how
people really kind of
socially accepted people
cross kind of racial
lines and boundaries.
So coming up in the early
'90s, I graduated high school
in 1990-- so going
off to Rutgers,
there were definitely
people that looked down
their nose-- black and
white and otherwise.
Right there were kind
of like a little bit
skeptical, like who's this
kid, coming up in this space,
airbrushing t-shirts,
talking about graffiti.
That's not really
graffiti, That's airbrush.
That's not authentic.
So what the book
attempts to do is
take what the best practices
of authenticity are.
And I assign this formula--
it's kind of convoluted.
It's a little clunky.
But I think it frames the
real important components
to creating an
authentic expression,
an authentic interaction,
communication,
and the components
just on a high level.
There is the notion
of the unique voice,
the role of selfishness,
one's creative selfishness
and intent, which is often
when we get all kumbaya
and want to design
by committee, we
lose that selfish perspective.
Truthfulness, being
defined by your ability
to do more than you say.
Because a lot culturally,
we're just busy talking.
And in this era of
social media, we almost
think because we
said it, we did it.
ROB KENNER: [CHUCKLES]
MARC ECKO: But it's not really.
Like talking and action-- two
discernibly different things.
So but really, I take
the piss out of it.
E Yeah, there's this guideline,
but it's not that prescriptive,
like (MOCK TELEVISION
ANNOUNCER VOICE]
here's step one through
five on how to be authentic
and have an authentic
interaction at work.
Right?
No, it's not like that.
It is by design philosophical
and modeled in a way
to kind of make you flatfooted
so that people kind of come
to the terms of well, that
was his way of prescribing
to the core spine of his brand,
which in his view, in my view,
was the desire to be as
transparent and as authentic
as possible, good,
bad and indifferent.
ROB KENNER: Now this idea of
selling out, as you mentioned,
is less of a hindrance
to hip hop today.
The pursuit of profit is nothing
to be ashamed of anymore.
And I would say probably one
of the cultural figures who
helped usher that
it in was Puffy.
MARC ECKO: Yeah, Sean Combs.
ROB KENNER: It's all
about the benjamins.
Yeah, we call him
Puffy from those days.
Diddy, today.
MARC ECKO: Diddy.
ROB KENNER: Talk about how
he served as a kind of a Yoda
for you.
MARC ECKO: Yeah, I talk
about in the book how
I have these kind of
unintentional Yodas,
that they don't necessarily
always dress or look the part.
And they don't always
answer the question
by answering the question but
rather by asking the question.
So in some ways, Puff was
like this interesting, almost
Cheshire cat-like
character, who seemed
to be able to be in more
than one place at once.
And I perceive that
brand of celebrity
as what, if I wanted
to kind of quote
"get that red carpet heat,"
the thing to parrot to.
And I quickly learned that
I wasn't built for that.
That's what I talk
about in the book.
But there was a lot
that he taught me just
in relationship to being more
true to what I was defining
as quote "success" for creating
media attention for myself,
rather than trying
to parrot to more
of a kind of brash,
entertainer style kind of grab
for media, which
came to him innately.
So there's many characters
like that throughout the book,
in my journey, that were
able to glean a lot from.
ROB KENNER: You
have a cover blurb
from George Lucas,
which is kind of baller.
MARC ECKO: Not bad.
ROB KENNER: I mean,
he goes on at length.
And there's a photo
of you two building.
I know you're a
big Star Wars fan.
How did you actually
connect with this guy,
who had such an impact on--
MARC ECKO: Well, one
of things I talk about
as a ingredient in the
formula of authenticity
is this notion of the
range of emotional impact.
And the importance of
creating emotional impacts
as a product of what you do.
It's not what you make, it's
how you make people feel.
So I use the anecdote on how
I got to George Lucas, who
I'm obviously a fanboy
of, and in a lot of ways,
I learn more from
studying his business,
in terms of how he configured
his business around licensing.
Then I did, let's say, out of
studying Calvin Klein or Ralph
Lauren, I was able
to extrapolate more--
it came to me, the
learnings of licensing
came to me more intuitively
through studying him,
than folks in the fashion space.
But the way that I got to
him, in that kind of pursuit
of creating emotional impact,
is that-- well, actually
funny enough, I saw
there was a fundraiser,
and they were going to honor
George Lucas here in the city.
And I got invited to it.
They wanted us to buy a table.
So I'm thinking oh shit,
George Lucas will be there.
I can bum rush
him, and it's going
to be like I can finally meet
him, get like a photo op.
This is pre-Instagram--
whoops, I'm
not supposed to say
Instagram inside of Google.
ROB KENNER: Oops!
Or I could've Google Plused
with him-- only kidding.
All right.
I think Google should
have an Instagram account.
I'm just saying I think
it would be funny.
I think it'd be funny.
All right, whatever.
ROB KENNER: We'll
edit that later.
AUDIENCE: [LAUGHTER]
MARC ECKO: There's the
uncomfortable Google
laugh in the back.
ROB KENNER: More
of this to come.
MARC ECKO: But I thought that
that would be really cool,
so sure enough, 11th hour,
about to go to this event.
I forget what the
crisis was, had
to go put out a
forest fire somewhere,
like in my production pipeline,
I had trouble overseas.
So we were just launching
at around that time complex,
and I remember I was going to
bring the new complex staff
and some of my echomarketing
marketing team to that dinner.
And at the 11th hour,
I find I can't go.
So it occurs to
me, I say I'm going
to send my action figure--
I have a 12-inch action
figure of George Lucas, this
really rare, collectible action
figure I got from like from
should Shebooya or somewhere
like in Tokyo somewhere, like
some like cool random toy spot.
Like the spot where they're like
"not for sale, not for sale,"
and you're like "its for sale."
ROB KENNER: You just
keeping peeling off.
MARC ECKO: Just
peeling off the bills.
So I say to my man, who
so one of my good friends
worked for me for years and
now has his own little agency.
A guy named Coltrane
Curtis, not so little.
I say train-- take a
picture with little George
and big George.
If there's anything
that happens tonight,
get a picture of little
George with big George.
Can you do that?
He's like I can do that, right.
I remember I come
back from the trip,
and he has printed
out-- those were
the days you printed photos?
At a pharmacy?
It's crazy?
Crazy technology.
So like Gutenberg style.
And he had a stack of photos
with Little George and Big
George together, and
like little George
and like real little
Martin Scorsese,
who's little in real life.
ROB KENNER: [GUFFAWS]
MARC ECKO: So there was
all these great phot--
so years later, victory.
So that was like
my first instance
of an emotional
impact as a product.
I don't know that's
what I was designing
in terms of that instance.
Right?
Years later, another
fundraiser, where
Spike Lee was celebrating
the anniversary of like 40
Acres and a Mule, and he did a
thing on like a Carnival Cruise
line, like a new Carnival Cruise
line, that pulled to the city.
And I said, of course,
I'm going to go.
And I didn't even
know that George Lucas
was going to be there.
So walk in, and I
see George Lucas.
He's like in my line of sight.
And he's wearing a white
linen, double breasted suit--
it was a Naval theme,
like a Navy theme.
He was looking like
Gatsby, like harsh.
You know, really,
like-- his hair.
I don't know how does that.
So I see him, and I walk up.
And I see that
there's just some guy.
this douchebags from
Kodak, getting in his ear
about how his-- [DEEP VOICE]
"George, your films just
don't look warm.
Like they used to, when
they were on film."
And he's just getting at him.
So I break out my
little BlackBerry
at the time, which
was like-- there
used to be a company
called BlackBerry.
And I had it with a
little Yoda etched in it.
So and I go [MAKES
SPACESHIP NOISES].
I walk right up to
him, really loud,
and I'm like [SOUND
BECOMES LIGHT SABER NOISE].
Like Lord Lucas,
is there any more
that I should remove their head.
And he starts laughing, like
the douchebag guy walks away.
I start to chat
and I'm like do you
remember meeting little George?
And he's like what
are you talking about?
That 12-inch action figure.
That was mine.
That was kind of the
way that I connected.
ROB KENNER: Wow, you blew
his mind right there.
MARC ECKO: Yeah!
So between the
[SPACESHIP/LIGHT_SABER_NOISE],
the saber sounds and
that much planning,
he was like you know what,
I will take a meeting.
So I asked for a meeting
to contemplate him,
if he would license
the archives to do
some stuff with our
fashion product.
And we did that for years.
So it was really cool,
ROB KENNER: Very cool.
Yeah, so with that have
been technically speaking
a swag bomb.
MARC ECKO: I think that's an
instance of-- because swag
bombs are usually solicited
via mail or by delivery.
ROB KENNER: But had
little George was sort of
like a three-years
prior swagger.
That was probably kind of
more of that notion of don't
underestimate.
When you want to make
an impact, on someone.
I mean don't take your
shirt in front of them.
Don't do like wacky
stuff like that
or like anti-social or
not too anti-social.
But there's something to be
said about deliberately thought
out meaningful
human interactions.
And that when you
could do something
bespoke for someone
and for young people
coming up with their businesses
and new products or services,
not to underestimate the
value of a those kind
of interactions.
Not to just presume, because
you sent an email with a PDF,
like that's going
to seal the deal.
And then the sense
of gratification
because hey, I checked the box.
I sent it.
Not to underestimate
showing up-- and again,
not being like stalker, weirdo--
of swag bonds in the book,
as how I did early
product placement, where
I would airbrush jackets
and T-shirts and give away
stuff to like emerging
celebrities in the music scene.
ROB KENNER: DJ Red
Alert was first.
MARC ECKO: Yeah, cool
DJ red alert, and was
see here, like a New York
City legendary iconic,
both influential, in
at the label level.
And on the radio level, in
terms of this relationship
with a tribe called
Quest, and all
of like the kind
of native tongue--
ROB KENNER: BCP!
MARC ECKO: Yeah,
BDP, all these guys.
But I would send-- those
were like mailed packages
but very customly made.
And a lot of people ask me that
are in services businesses,
that are like well, I guess how
swag bombs could be meaningful,
because you had a product
and you could customize it
into an actual tangible product.
And I said it's hard
for me to do that,
because I have some
sass, B2B, some product.
And I said, well, bullshit.
Your product is
ultimately satisfying
some kind of analog thing
for whoever is using it,
either it's saving them
time or it's saving them
money or a blend of all
of the above, whatever.
So you thinking
about what object
expresses or is a metaphor
for what your product does.
And delivering it to
someone, there's value to it.
It's old school, but
there's real value to that.
And a lot of people
just think well,
I send flowers or
a bottle of Wine
or a nice handwritten note.
No, ike really?
Be deliberate and
think about that stuff.
It's really powerful,
and to this day,
I get things-- like the things
that really impact me are--
when peopl and since
I've wrote the book,
I've seen to beginning
a lot more swag bombs.
MARC ECKO: All right, then
people are catching on.
MARC ECKO: Yeah.
At least they're
trying to play to that.
And I warn people in the
book, please don't do that.
ROB KENNER: And
not to the house.
MARC ECKO: Right,
now to the house.
Which I've gotten,
which is really weird.
ROB KENNER: Creepy.
No, but I love the
image of you straight
spamming the fax
machine of 98.7 KISS
while Red Alert is on the air.
MARC ECKO: That's right.
ROB KENNER: And
then, eventually you
send them the custom
jacket, and he gives you
the big shout out on air.
MARC ECKO: Yeah, I would
go to the Kinko's, and I
would draw these really
custom-drawn illustrated cover
letters.
And I would just
spam the hell out
of-- like he had to
recognize my solicitation.
I figured I'm worthy
of a shout-out.
And then he eventually did.
And that was very cool.
ROB KENNER: It's good stuff.
You talk about a dream of
Tommy Hilfiger in the book,
how he comes to you in a vision.
And it's a kind of a
surreal image actually.
You show up at the sort
of imaginary-- Hilfiger
perfect chateau with sort of
mannequin model characters, all
of them.
But then he's a
little bit disheveled
and it seems a little different
than you might have expected.
MARC ECKO: Well,
what I was trying
to do in the subtext
of that little--
and it's a persistent theme
throughout the book, which
is this notion that
seems to be people
have really kind of stuff to
with the book, which is look we
live in a culture where
perception is reality.
I mean my first PR
person told me that.
And the book, I try to
testify, say, hey, well,
actually reality is reality,
ROB KENNER: OK.
MARC ECKO: And a
lot of our judgments
and our relationships
with other people
are informed by those
games of perception.
Again back to the very
first question of the brand
you perceive skin to the
world versus the brand that's
like the interior, inside
guts of the skin brand.
So that dream is
kind of me taking
the piss out of my own
relationship with the fashion
industry, my expectations
of acceptance or kind
of peer review, my wantedness
of a peer acceptance
from whom I perceive as
the elite of fashion.
Because those were
the gatekeepers.
So in the dream, which
look, I embellish
because it's a book, right?
And I was trying to be
a little bit hyperbolic,
but I do recall that
whole interaction
and timing being
very serendipitous,
because I had an
interaction with Tommy
in real life at that same time.
So it's kind of almost like
my psyche warning me like,
dude it's not going to
be what you think it is.
Like it's not what you
think it's going to be like
you visualize this
ultra sexy glamorous
perfect like
everything-- because I
imagine how we perceive it to
be like to work for Google.
But it probably like for a
lot of people socks, Right?
So let's be-- not terrible.
ROB KENNER: We can talk
in private afterwards.
I
MARC ECKO: I mean,
stock options are great.
But I mean your boss is a dick.
Not Larry and Sergey, but like
the guy you really report to.
Because people are
emotional creatures.
But I think that
section of the book kind
of kind of getting
comfortable in my skin,
with my own relationship
with my career,
because I always
kind of begrudged
like I was the schlepper who
painted t-shirts in my garage,
because if that was
something to not be proud of,
rather than use that kind
of rough around the edges,
crunchy on the outside, soft
in the middle kind of vibe
as my entryway in business.
And I talk about that's when
I was launching Mark Echo
Cut-and-Sew , and
so I had a case,
a fierce case of
Ralph Lauren-itis.
it's like I try to pair the kind
of best practices of the elite,
best in class, in an industry.
Like he's an ambassador-grade
level practitioner.
And what the world
doesn't need someone
being a bad copy
of Ralph Lauren.
The world needs Mark
Echo growing up.
And I thought that
the world needed
another-- like do as Ralph does.
And not that Ralph
Lauren-itis, it
wasn't to begrudge or
disparage Ralph Lauren.
He's G-O-A-T, right?
Like "goat" -- real
grace of all time.
But that can happen
in other industries.
I know other guys in
technology, engineers, marketing
guys that have this kind
of weird relationship
with what they perceive
to be greatness,
and then they end up a lot of
their career actually finding
their way by parodying them
rather than kind of embracing
good, bad, indifferent,
the things that
define their strengths and
sometimes their weaknesses
to differentiate them.
And I kind of came comfortable
in my own skin, saying look,
I'm an artist first.
I'm an Illustrator.
I'm a strong Illustrator.
Like I have way ahead of
my fashion design skills.
So I've now with
older age become
more comfortable, just
for better or worse,
embracing that
kind of clunkiness
and saying oh,
that's what's going
to set my brand-- differentiate
my brand, rather than me trying
to parrot and be
a "me too" version
of someone else's brand.
Well, you're into polo
from Slick Rick days.
That was the gold standard.
ROB KENNER: Polo cologne too.
Aw man.
MARC ECKO: Yeah, man.
ROB KENNER: So let's talk
about complex real quick.
We have some of the complex
oh jeez in the building,
shout to Brendan,
Jack and Donnie.
ROB KENNER: Thank
you guys for coming.
And we roll deep
today, but I mentioned
those three in particular
because you guys
remember when Complex decided
to do this crazy website thing.
At the time, print media was
the shit and doing website
was this other thing
that you did on the side.
And, I think,
Brendan, at one point,
you expressed doubt
whether it would ever
reach a million page views.
So anyway now it's
depending when
you check [INAUDIBLE]
up among the top 200
sites on the whole internet.
Tell us why people told
you Complex was a bad idea.
MARC ECKO: Well, because
I make sweatshirts, right?
Because you're supposed
to like stay in your lane.
And the desire to create
it came from a place
where I as a buyer of media
and as this guy who came up
in that '80s diaspora,
and kind of watching
the mainstreaming of hip
pop and its influence
to kind of like have this
convergence thing happen.
In the late '80s, it
was crossing over.
Come the mid late '90s, people
are like oh, it's convergence.
They started looking at
it this way obliquely.
But as a media buyer,
I would get frustrated
because if I wanted to kind of
make a presentation in men's
fashion or do like
a better ware thing.
It was hard to get convincingly
the edit community at GQ
to take that stuff seriously.
They would take your
dollars but the advertising
and because of their kind of
disposition and their view,
the cultural view on streetwear.
They were like eh, it's
not really fashion,
but where was I going to launch
like the Mark Echo brand?
I had to put-- like
you'd would launch
your media-bought dollars
there, because that's
where men's fashion
goes-- "Details," "GQ."
Same thing for music, if I
wanted to do like alternative
or at the time my European
distributors were into this
thing that was called,
at the time-- I mean,
I don't know that
they called it EDM,
but it was like early
EDM-- like you'd be in--
ROB KENNER: House.
MARC ECKO: Yeah, like
you'd be in "ERB Magazine."
And then if you're hip hop,
you're like the "Source,"
and if you're skate,
you're "Thrasher."
So the idea was that
I just saw, maybe
in a slightly deluded
state, that there
were these
inefficiencies, and then I
saw this convergence thing
happening, that things were not
just black or white, just hip
hop or alternative or rock
or just high and low.
They were complex.
ROB KENNER: You unlabeled
media, basically.
MARC ECKO: Yeah, well,
I mean, now at 41
with the book behind
me, I could say that,
but I didn't think
that at the time.
I just was like a
little bit like wow,
I'm looking at my media spend.
Our business is growing.
As a percentage
of revenue, you're
starting to buy some
serious media dollars.
You're like fuck,
we could do this.
We can make a
business out of this,
rather than just inefficiently
buy media, and then maybe
hopefully solve something
for the rest of the space,
and help verify and
validate the space, which
is a lot of entrepreneurs
that came up within the skate
and street scene have
helped kind of legitimize
as a community our
business practices
and create scale for
us as an ecosystem.
So to Rich Antoniello's
credit, who's
my partner and
CEO of Complex, it
was really his
leadership in 2007,
which was not an
easy year financially
for the Echo business
certainly, and the way
we had the businesses
configured at the time
is that even though Complex
was pointing north from just
bringing-- he actually
delivered immediate--
that print thing in the
black, which is kind of rare.
It's kind of crazy to think you
could make print at that time
profitable.
But his dependency
on our financing
was all contingent on how well
or not well, the Echo business
was doing.
So we had him on-- I mean, two
nickels, rubbing two nickels,
making fireworks thing.
And really it was
his leadership that
productized and visualized
the online play.
And he just was a very
analog kind of perspective.
It was like, look, I've got all
these ad sales executives who
are really qualified, but I
can't keep up with their costs
on 330 circ print product.
The math wasn't lining up.
So we naively, for better
or worse and iteratively
jumped in.
So we were very fortunate being
and believing in this concept
at the right time,
right place as well.
ROB KENNER: But it wasn't only
Rich's vision and his business
acumen, but also his wrestling
skills that came into play,
I understand.
MARC ECKO: Yeah, oh
yeah, his physicality
to basically coerce
people physically.
ROB KENNER: I mean,
I'm thinking--
MARC ECKO: It's all in the book.
It's on page 184, I think.
I'm kidding.
ROB KENNER: I'm thinking
of a particular individual
that he coerced.
MARC ECKO: Oh yeah, my
former partner Seth.
They had to physically wrestle
it out in order to get--
ROB KENNER: A
budget negotiation.
MARC ECKO: Yeah, a budget.
There was a physical match.
ROB KENNER: And may
the best man win.
MARC ECKO: Seth really thought
he was going to have him.
But yeah, to his credit
and then the teams.
And it's just been amazing
platform that's been built
and a lot of really
intelligent and creative folks.
And I'm very blessed
to be a part of it.
ROB KENNER: Another of
my favorite anecdotes
in the book, and just in terms
of taking a difficult situation
and flipping it, is
the whole Where's
Echo nontrade show
that turned Vegas
upside down during
Magic Weekend.
Can you just give a
little bit of the genesis
of how that came about.
MARC ECKO: That also
spoke in the framework
to that kind of the whole notion
of range of emotional impact,
right?
Here we were at a place
where we're really
on the balls of our
ass financially.
ROB KENNER: On the
balls of your ass?
MARC ECKO: You know like the
flattest part of your ass,
when you stretch your legs.
And like the part
that if you sit on it,
like there's no flesh there?
You really got to--
ROB KENNER: Ouch.
MARC ECKO: Yeah.
So it hurts, right?
So we were financially
in a pickle.
That's in the book,
how we got there.
We kind of self-made
a kind of self-wound.
But we were at a place
where the cost of the trade
shows and the optionality
of funding those trade shows
just was not an option.
But the irony at
that time is that we
had a massive pull
in the market.
So like from a
supply/demand business,
like the demand side was high.
And we couldn't afford
to fund the trade show.
So we'd bought the space,
so we leased the space
with the folks that
managed those conventions.
This was in Las Vegas.
It's like an industry--
the American big sportswear
industry trade show.
It's called Magic.
And so we were already on the
hook for whatever that was.
But the notion of
having to fund the booth
and shipping all the staff,
that option wasn't great.
So we ran an audible and
we said, OK, let's just
ask the industry where's Echo?
So we own the booth.
So our set up costs will just be
the rental fee of a red velvet
rope going around the perimeter
of this oversized gargantuan
booth that we really
couldn't afford.
And that's one of the
reasons we were in debt.
And in the middle,
there'd be a table,
and there'd be a little
tea stand or whatever,
and it would say "Where's
Echo," and then we
proceed to run up a
risk assessment of what
it would cost to basically
bomb Vegas with stickers
and we paste posters
and like cardboard,
real like Wu-Tang style.
We just got up
everywhere in Vegas.
And we took a suite
at whatever hotel,
something decent
but modest budget.
And that's where we
did our bookings from.
And we ended up booking more
at that show-- our nonshow--
than we had ever in the
history of the trade
shows at that time.
ROB KENNER: But the first day
was looking a little grim.
MARC ECKO: It is looking grim.
And it turned around,
it all turned around.
And it informed our
view just generally
on how to then-- cause
after you did that show,
you're like we can't come back.
You can't be like fuck you Magic
and then come back and then
be like "we're back!"
So we found one of
their Achilles heels,
which was right across the
street from the convention
center , there's this really--
it's kind of-- I don't want
to say anything
disparaging-- and it's a bar,
and we rented the
parking lot of that bar.
And we put up what we call the
middle finger pavilion, which
was like right in the line
of sight of the trade show
and walking distance, so
we end up doing our trade
shows outside of the trade show.
ROB KENNER: The middle
finger pavilion.
MARC ECKO: Yeah, that
was the nickname.
Yeah.
ROB KENNER: That's
just remarkable.
Are we getting the signal?
OK, well, this seems
like a great time
to turn the microphones over
to those who are in attendance.
I know that you want to know
more about the middle finger
pavilion or where exactly
the balls of the ass
is or anything else like that.
No, but please, if you have
questions, the mic is open.
Don't be shy.
Step up.
You don't need a swag
bomb to get this audience.
Yes, here we go.
MARC ECKO: All right.
Someone will ask a question.
ROB KENNER: We got a live one.
AUDIENCE: How did you
get your [INAUDIBLE]?
ROB KENNER: Oh
wait, see, you got
to stand up and come
to the mic for that.
She moved first, so you're next.
MARC ECKO: Go ahead, dude.
Go ahead.
ROB KENNER: No, no, you first.
Go.
AUDIENCE: I win, Hi,
my name's Mahallat
and I'm a big Complex fan.
So I guess since there's
a lot of you guys,
this can be for everybody.
A friend of mine recently,
we got into an argument
because he said that Complex
is for men in the same way
that BuzzFeed is
strictly for women.
And I disagree, because
I read Complex every day.
I don't read BuzzFeed everyday.
And obviously the
articles are better.
So I wanted to know what
you guys thought about that.
ROB KENNER: Very
perceptive reader.
MARC ECKO: We think that you're
right that the articles are
better.
AUDIENCE: Just if
you guys purposely--
there's some articles
obviously I can't get with,
like all the men's
fashion, obviously,
isn't going to work for me.
So I thought, just
curious, if there
were plans on
expanding more for--
ROB KENNER: Women?
AUDIENCE: --women
in that fashion,
or if you guys think of it
like a primarily male brand,
and just what you guys
think about that overall.
MARC ECKO: I think, I
can't speak for everyone,
but I could probably-- I
think the consensus internally
is that we do what
we do really well.
And our disposition
is to serve and try
to delight this young
male demographic.
We do know that
there is a crossover,
because a lot of the cultural
conversations are broad.
But our framework
is when we paint
a picture of the archetype,
we are focused mostly
just on men for right now.
I think though,
like I said, there's
a lot of these conversations
that are generally broad,
and there are a
lot of women that
work inside the company that
actually inform the edit.
So you're seeing their tone and
vibe come through the content.
AUDIENCE: Cool.
Thank you.
MARC ECKO: And for now, it's
I think a platform for dudes.
ROB KENNER: And
guys read "Cosmo"
to get intel on the other side.
Probably works both ways.
Now, you had a good question.
Please come to the mic.
AUDIENCE: How did you
originally get backing behind--
MARC ECKO: Financial backing?
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
MARC ECKO: I talk about it in
the book, which again speaks
to the whole subtext
of perception, reality,
because my perception was that
I'd been servicing and creating
relationships with a lot
of celebrities at the time.
And I presumed like
that celebrity there,
X, like in this one instance-- I
don't know if you guys remember
a group called Bell
Biv Devoe They're
derivative from New Edition.
There's a guy named
Michael Bivins, who's
a real entrepreneurial cat,
very successful music producer.
I actually was air
brushing for him
and actually managed
to get my friend,
Cale Brock, who's
mentioned in the book,
signed to his record label
through that interaction.
So I was going down the rabbit
hole of meeting music execs,
and I just perceived--
I perceived, well,
they have money.
Look at the videos.
Look at their influence.
So I kept beating
pounding the drum.
If it was Spike Lee,
soliciting Spike Lee,
soliciting Biv, soliciting
a whole bunch of people
that were just specifically
music industry.
And what ended up
happening is one
of those unsuspecting
characters, who didn't look
and dress the part of
celebrity, became my partner,
a guy named Seth Gerszberg, who
literally put the first $5,000
into the company.
And he kind of was my
commercialization beast.
As a band goes, the composition
of the original company
was my twin sister Marci, who
I talk about this in the book.
She was like governance.
Like she governed, kept the
boys from killing each other.
And then there was
my partner Seth
who was like the brute force
and the commercialization.
And I was kind of like the
swag and the branded and kind
of the emotional
part of the equation.
But in tandem, we went out
there and kind of slowly
from that initial
$5,000 investment,
he managed to
coerce another group
that he was doing business with.
I talk about it in the book.
And they were our
initial seed investors.
And we eventually
bought them out.
But it's not an easy--
getting funding,
that's the trick
question, right?
Or that's the $25,000 question.
No pun intended, or
pun maybe intended.
But there's no single one
way to do it obviously.
And what's so fascinating
today with what's
going on culturally with
like platforms like Indigogo
or Kickstarter and a lower
path, a lower threshold,
because of Google,
the fact you could
kind of, from Google
or not, just directly
go to Ali Baba or wherever and
source things domestically,
oversees.
The barrier to enter,
if you want to learn,
if there's a wantedness,
is sufficiently lower.
But it's that much noisier now.
So that's why branding
is a really crucial part
of the equation.
AUDIENCE: Thanks.
MARC ECKO: Cheers.
AUDIENCE: My name's Kennedy.
I appreciate you
coming out today.
My question is did you ever
feel lost on this journey.
I imagine that a lot
of entrepreneurs, they
feel like they're the
only one in the world that
feels a certain way, and
clearly had that drive
to keep you going.
How do you keep
yourself focused,
or did you have a
mentor that said
you know what, just shut
up and keep on doing it.
Did you have anything
sort of like that?
MARC ECKO: Yeah, I think
that there's a couple things
that if you took them
away from me in my life
that I probably really
be well below average.
One is having grown up in
Lakewood, New Jersey, which
was a very diverse place,
and at a time where
hip hop was emerging.
So the lens in which
I view the world
is viewed through
that lens of Lakewood.
So that gives me a
very different kind
of cultural view on stuff.
So that's one.
Two is I've a twin sister.
And everything they
say about twins
is true in terms of best
friend and all that.
So, if you were to
take Marci, and she's
as a character
throughout the book,
I describe her as
my ghost of reason.
So in a lot of ways, I had
this really interesting yin
to my yang, who's someone
who's not a visual artist.
She doesn't need
the fanfare, maybe
in the way that I'm
more of a narcissistic.
So I had that throughout
my adolescence
and then in my career,
and to this day,
where I still work with
Marci very closely,
that served me in a way
that I can't contemplate
life or business without that.
And my relationship with
mentors had been-- it's
funny because I
think a lot of people
prescribe to that idea of
(PATHETIC VOICE) "will you
be my mentor?"
And they kind of think of
them like their shrink.
And they meet with them
once every three weeks
at the coffee shop.
And it's kind of
like consistent,
mostly inconsistent,
but at parties,
"I want you to meet my mentor."
I imagine that works.
I know people that
that's worked for.
But I found that when there's
a wantedness to learn,
their learning comes.
It's there to be gleaned.
And that you could have
mentor-like relationships
in the most unsuspecting
places and in a manner that
doesn't necessarily consume
their schedule on that kind
of road every two three
weeks kind of a way.
But alone, yeah, of course.
I mean, I'm human, right?
But there's nothing--
I hate to break it
to myself or to any
entrepreneur, like we're not
unique in feeling alone.
It's like welcome to trying
to do shit differently.
Again, that is, again, a subtext
of the book-- this relationship
of goal keepers
versus gatekeepers.
The goal keepers, being
ultimately who you're building,
trying to execute your vision
for and the gatekeepers,
being those that guard, kind
of the influencers, the media,
maybe a buyer, could be a dean
or an academic relationship.
But those gatekeeper
relationships,
so much of what we often do,
we want consent from them.
We want to comply to their
standard and there's a want,
a cultural wantedness.
And I would challenge
today, more than ever,
that you've to be
very cognizant and ask
yourself are you not
inadvertently building
your product or service
for the wrong audience,
versus having a
real intellectually
honest conversation around
who the goal keeper is,
who at the consumer
level is really--
and what do they really
need to kind of be contented
and to judge you as either
executing or not executing.
Because often you have that
social pressure that's here,
and doesn't have shit to
do with your core business.
And in fashion, I've
seen way too many
designers-- people
way smarter than me,
more talented, more creative,
build their business there,
and then end up with a
business that's not relevant.
There's disconnected
from a consumer,
like a real-- at scale.
So that's how I'd answer that.
ROB KENNER: So the gatekeepers
really aren't as important
as they think they are.
MARC ECKO: Oh, again, it comes
from that 12-year sentence
that we all had to go through.
Right?
We all wanted the gold star.
We're taught, but in a
self-directed, self-taught
pursuit, which is really the
only path of entrepreneurship.
It's like your greatest learning
kind of comes on some wax
on, wax off shit.
You have to be added, right?
And you want that guidance,
you want that governance,
so that you're not just
wandering in the dark.
But to think that you have to
create the evidence of what's
good or complying, and
there's that standard,
like the way that we're
taught, K through 12,
and that's how it works
in the real world.
It's really quite not like that.
And we get very
romantic, especially
in the big cities,
west coast, east coast,
living in these kind of
bubbles of gatekeeper-dominated
conversations.
And that's definitely
something that I've
learned to kind of be a little
more flip about and not where
you're out there
in fantasy land,
with this fantasy version of out
wandering, inside joke style.
But I think that we give too
much credence-- in culture
we're at a place where our
university system don't work.
They don't work.
OK, like our education
really fucked and fucked.
What we need is like
Google or someone
like that smart
to figure it out.
Because we're all chasing
like this big oil approach
that's all gatekeeper dependent.
And that's not really
how we're going
to end up being independent
in the real world
or financially independent.
So that's a real cultural issue.
ROB KENNER: We're getting
the timeout signal.
My man Jacob.
Thanks, Marc.
MARC ECKO: Thank you.
Thank you all for coming.
AUDIENCE: [APPLAUSE]
MARC ECKO: Thanks to Google.
ROB KENNER: And thanks to Google
for gChat and Google Docs,
which is how we run in the
Complex and OG Chat which
is their new product,
coming out of Google labs.
This is the OG Chat.
MARC ECKO: Right.
We're the engineers
on that product.
OG chat.
It's very cool.
It's a big thing.
ROB KENNER: And there's
books in the back, right?
MARC ECKO: Yeah, man.
ROB KENNER: All right.
MARC ECKO: Cheers.
Thanks, brother.
Cheers.